[موسيقى]
النيازكهما اجسام فضائيه كطيح على الارض
كتسقط على الارض
النووي
[موسيقى]
الرحال هما الاولين
درجه
الثمن بحال الجمال الاخضر
[موسيقى]
اغلى
ما نقدرش
[موسيقى]
النيازك هي حجاره اذا جايه من الفضاء
الخارجي الاصل ديالها اما من القمر او لا
المريخ او من الكويكبات ديال الكويكبات
يصطدمو
[موسيقى]
جوج
حوايجونا مباشره للارض غادي يكون عندنا
حجر نيزكي من الكويكبات ولا يصطدم بالقمر
والمريخ ويحيد منه واحد الشظايا في هذه
المرحله الثانيه غادي يكون عندنا نيزك من
القمر او المريخ
[موسيقى]
عبد الكريم ابن مدينه
هو واحد المصدر ديال عباد غير ماشي كتقلب
وكتلقى والو
[موسيقى]
عليك الله
لان النيازك عندهم واحد القيمه ماديه فهنا
في المغرب كاينين شباب ولاو تعطوا
[موسيقى]
يقلبوا على النيازك كان قبل في
الناس يقلبوا عليه دابا ولاو الالاف اذا
طاح نيزك حتى كيلقاو
[موسيقى]
من هذا المجال تعرفت على واحد السابق
سميتو علي المغاري وهما كيتعامل معنا
كنبيعو معاه المعقول
عمل ديالي ميداني كنقلب على النيازك او
كنشري عند الرحال من بعد كان نبيعه من
المتاحف والعلماء المهم
[تصفيق]
الفرق بين الحجر
الارضيش خبير ما يمكنش تحدو
النيازك كل هذا تقول
كاينين الناس اللي كانتواصلوا معهم حتى
هما تيكون عندهم هذاك الاعتقاد لان كلنا
تكون تقدر تكون
[موسيقى]
المغناطيسيه شحال كتجبد يعني هذه والنوع
ديال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شخص نيزك اول حاجه
كيديني العين المكان كناخد المعلومات على
ديك المنطقه شنو سميتها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والحجم ديالو والكتله ديالو
[موسيقى]
هو
180 درجه
[موسيقى]
هنا في الارض كانوا
الديناصورات 65 مليون عام الانسان القديم
شاف حجره
عندنا هاد النقوش صخريه في المتحف فيها
واحد جوج سطور مكتوبه بالامازيغيه القديمه
الى الشمس يرمينا بالحجاره
في العالم العربي والافريقيا
اذا هو هذا بزاف ديال الناس خصوصا من تونس
من الجزائر من العراق للتاكد من هذه
الحجاره ديالهم واش هي نيزك او لا
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للصحراء ديال المغرب كبيره فيها
التنوع فيها مناطق رمليه في مناطق
فيها احجار فيها مناطق جبليه في مناطق
فيها وداد يعني كاينين المناطق اللي
كيسقتو فيهم
الانهار في الجبال في الصحه حريف صعيب
صعيب جدا انك مع البحث باش تلقى نيزك في
الصحراء الشائعه
بعض المرات راه كنديرو الرحله الرحله ديال
15 يوم 20 كانديروها في الصحراء يعني
وكندورو وكان تحول من هنا لهنا لهنا لهنا
مسافه طويله تيكون هذه هي اللي المهنه
ديالنا صعبه في البحث لذلك كنستاهنوا
بالرحل
هما الاولين اللي كيشوفو السقوط ديال
النيزك
وهما اللولين اللي كيلقطوه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يرحل
[موسيقى]
فمن 2004 بدينا معهم حنايا مشينا لبزاف
عند الروحان درنا محاضرات باش نعيهم
معنا الادوات
علماء في النيازك
غرامك
بالنسبه للسعر ديال النيازك النيازك
العاديه اللي رخيصه الثمن هي كتسقط دائما
اللي مصدر ديالها الحزام ديال الارض ولكن
ملي كيجينا شي نيزك من الكوكب بعيد هذا
تاتكون عنده واحد القيمه كبيره
تترواح ما بين 500 اورو ولا حتى الانف
الغرام غاليه
كيلو ديال ديال
غاليه كاين اللي ما عندهاش
بحال الجمال الاخضر الجمال الاخضر
تلقى في الصحراء المغربيه اول نيزك في
العالم كيجي من عطارد
الثمن
لانه هو المعلومات العلميه التي يعطيه
مهمه جدا للانسان هذا المعلومات
الا بغيتيها خاصك رحله فضائيه الكواكب
كنز للعلماء لا يحتاجون الى الذهاب الى
المريخ
من خلال حجر صغير
فهمنا اشنو كاين في الكوكب في الكوكب
المريخ
النيازك هما سفراء الكون على الارض
لانها هي قطع من هذيك الكواكب ومن
الكويكبات
كتورينا واش فيها الماء المواد اللي كتكون
الغازات من كتكون كتورينا المعادن اللي ما
عندناش حنا في الارض باش تكون واحد
التجاره كيفاش يوصلوا ذوك المعادن النافسه
ويجيبوها الارض الحياه تقدر تكون مستقبلا
في الفضاء
النيازك غتغير المستقبل ديال الانسان يعني
غتكون السياحه الفضائيه يكونو مراكب
فضائيه تقدر تكون صراعات فضائيه بالدول
حنا درنا واحد الارضيه اللي غيمشيو عليها
اجيال العلماء القادمين
[موسيقى]